a man who police say planned to kill
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh is
charged with attempted murder this
morning the 26 year old suspect was
arrested near kavanaugh's home in
maryland early yesterday morning he had
traveled there from california where he
lives police say he was carrying a case
full of potential tools for an attack
jan crawford is outside the supreme
court jan so what else do we know about
the suspect
well vlad the suspect's name is nicholas
john roski and according to court
documents he believed that killing
justice kavanaugh would give his life a
purpose we're also hearing from his
family members who say they never
imagined that he could be involved in
something like this
last night fbi agents raided the
california home of the man accused of
attempting to kill justice brett
kavanaugh word spread quickly of the
plot shocked that it was right here
and a nice family good neighbors
according to an fbi affidavit nicholas
roski got out of a taxi outside
kavanaugh's home just after 1am
wednesday
roughly 10 minutes later police say they
got a 9-1-1 call according to the
affidavit roski was turning himself in
expressing that he had come from
california to kill a supreme court
justice had a firearm in his suitcase
and was having suicidal thoughts law
enforcement arrested him around 1 50 a.m
recovering a glock 17 pistol ammunition
pepper spray and other supplies rosky
allegedly told a detective he was upset
about the leaked supreme court draft
decision that would overturn roe versus
wade
the leaked opinion sparked protests
outside conservative justices homes as
well as the supreme court this is
exactly
exactly the kind of event
that many feared republicans and
democrats alike wednesday renewed the
call for legislation that would offer
increased security to federal justices
and their family members the senate
unanimously passed such a bill last
month but is stalled in the house we
shouldn't have to give up our lives to
do our job u.s district judge esther
solis was the target of an attack two
years ago a disgruntled lawyer for a
former plaintiff came to her home in new
jersey where he shot and killed her son
as for roski cbs news met his
grandfather outside their home in
california he seemed shocked by the news
would you ever consider him someone who
might be
you know implicated and threatening
no absolutely not
now roski also allegedly expressed
concerns that justice kavanaugh could
roll back gun regulations if he is
convicted he faces up to 20 years in
federal prison and here at the supreme
court the building and the justices
remain under heightened security as the
country awaits that final decision on
abortion rights which is expected
sometime this month michelle
jan this sounds ominously like that john
gresham
book and film the pelican brief first
thing that went through my mind
thank you so much for your coverage